what's going on reject nation I'm Greg
and I John so we're gonna watch another
trailer really runner 2049 yeah I'm kind
of no one than to keep releasing footage
I still want to see this movie
yeah don't worry God will be you don't
need to keep convincing me because I
already have already but I don't think
you're going to get to a point where
you're like you know I saw like for
trailers but my nighttime I got to this
one I realize I want to see this please
don't spider-man this yeah that's all of
the thing before we go into this trailer
gonna give a shout out to diego Chaidez
diego her trailer loved the shot my ball
20:49 i get the helm in this case in
india where to find it
you push people to do tracks much prefer
that a alternative help
yeah about every alien civilizations
those goats off the back of slaves
Providence winter but I call back some
may I have a look and he has the key
I think it sounded we bought ourselves a
war if your job wants putting want ask
you some questions
what happened covered my tracks and
scramble the records we were being
hunted
[Music]
although you're here
you do not know what a new suit
you alone
bring it to me
two enemy and mess up in this riff did
break the world
[Music]
there you go
[Music]
the future of the species is fun
[Music]
gie rising oh dang oh yeah I mean we're
gonna do a trailer review on a separate
video but this trailer was uh I thought
it was rewarding I feel like a lot of
people might find this trailer to be you
know a little bit more heavy on
information and the other ones as they
probably will be it happens in your
release more trailers yeah you get more
and more information that you probably
are wanting at the time but at the same
time it does enhance the mystery element
of it you know the first Blade Runner
was rather simple premise for the world
that's set up and here it seems like
there's a lot more at stake it's about
there's a lot more things with humanity
being at stake and Jared Leto seems like
a defined Nicolas Cage villain hahaha
great Nic Cage impression you've got
going on there posing a lot of questions
that we want answers to questions that I
didn't think to ask and also it seems
like they might reveal there isn't voter
replicate or not now we're making a
definitive edition it bounces I don't
know we need three more cuts after 2014
I know fine now yeah yeah I hope they do
that with this you're like Denis
Villeneuve two cuts that really Scott
going to go to edit everybody make its
own cutter Deniz own movie and then he's
going to go back and make his own like
five prequel movies yeah I feel like in
this trailer we got a lot of the same
stuff that makes me excited for this
movie but we also got to see and hear
from a few more characters we got to
hint at a few more of the things that
are you know like you said the driving
mysteries of the movie and I feel like
with this trailer I've gotten all that I
want in terms of lead up and advertise
yeah I'm mulling some of these details
over in my head and now I just want to
see the movie and it looks like they're
also happen up the action a lot it does
yeah it looks like they're they're kind
of bringing everything you want from
this everything's a little bit bigger
I'm excited for it I really am I'm
excited them movie I'm looking forward
to most coming out later this year yeah
more than the last Jedi around who's
that upsetting who did I just said by
saying that I want to see this more than
a Star Wars movie day you're shy dad's
first of all the amount you contribute
patreon I just want to give you a heads
up your shirt is on the way for some
reason we order those shirts they take a
while to come and take a minute they
take a long minute but it's on its way
so let's why may as well as your letter
but my friend I wanted to tell you Diego
why haven't you been into Google
Hangouts yet dude distributed enough to
be a part of the Google hangout sessions
coming around like a month now every
time we have a Google hangout really I'm
too busy doing my jujitsu fighting I
have to train so I can survive in the
ring I have to win a match like that's
more important I'll focus on your goals
dude dude it's about hanging out talking
movies and talking about life with us
and asking each other random questions
to get to learn very useful fittings but
the training on hold and maybe I can
hire you to come out here and get rid of
that gardener for me well check out our
trailer review you can subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification out
he is that John Humphrey on Twitter and
Instagram social media manager of Blum
house com yeah go check out our trailer
we